luego de cinco años y dos increíbles
juegos el momento de terminar una de las
mejores y más violentas teologías
finalmente llegó y gears of war 3 le dio
un épico cierre a la historia de los
soldados más musculosos que este mundo
ha visto
como cualquier persona normal soy
alguien que le tiene mucho cariño al
software en especial a la trilogía
original los clásicos el gran inicio que
fue el original la innovación y la
maravillosa historia del segundo y lo
que para mí se convertiría en el mejor
juego de la saga el agente curse of war
3 y es que si con el segundo juego ya se
habían superado con gears of war 3
alcanzaron la cima de la divertidísima y
sangrienta violencia en videojuegos
seamos honestos las peleas por la
supervivencia de la humanidad nunca
fueron tan divertidas porque nos cierran
la [ __ ] boca desde que despertemos a su
madre monstruos gigantes grandes
personajes brazos del tamaño de un melón
y una historia que le da un cierre
perfecto a la trilogía este juego lo
tiene todo este es sin duda alguna es mi
juego favorito de toda la saga aún
recuerdo que cuando se estrenó todo el
mundo estaba feliz por poder jugarlo
pero triste es porque era el final de la
trilogía
[Música]
ya han pasado casi 11 años desde que la
guerra entre locus y humanos terminó y
para celebrarlo hoy te voy a mostrar 30
curiosidades secretos y detalles de
gears of war 3
[Música]
lo sientes
jesús portón
y por todos los que has matado perra
gears of war 3 fue estrenado en
septiembre del 2011 y para el momento de
su estreno la saga ya había vendido más
de un billón de copias alrededor del
mundo convirtiéndola en una de las sagas
más exitosas de xbox sólo por detrás del
jefe maestro y sus poderosos pectorales
aunque este juego no cambia demasiadas
cosas con respecto al juego anterior una
de las cosas más innovadoras que agrego
fue el modo bestia en donde podrías
convertirte en cualquiera de estos
bichos y partirle toda su madre a marcus
ya los demás es una pena que este modo
de juego no se volvió a incluir en
ningún otro gears of war y lo más
divertido que tenía el juego los lambent
fueron diseñados de manera distinta que
los locos con la intención de que
pudieran atacar y hacer más daño al
jugador sin importar si todo su
musculoso cuerpo estuviera cubierto esto
lo hicieron para motivar a los jugadores
a no quedarse en un solo lugar sino
moverse por todo el mapa para atacar a
los enemigos
originalmente se tenía planeado que y
fuera quien le prestará su voz a james
en este juego pero debido a la falta de
tiempo por parte de drake finalmente fue
michael jordan que le daría la voz a
gates en el inicio del juego y se nos
presenta golpeando una vieja máquina de
dulces a ver si le puedes sacar algo
aunque al final no lo logra pero una vez
asumamos el control de marcus e
interactuamos con la máquina un par de
veces nosotros sí conseguiremos el dulce
que james no pudo sacar a este es un
rapero bastante exitoso y como no
también es un gran fan de gears of war
por lo que él personalmente le pidió a
cliff bleszinski que no sea cabrón y lo
dejara interpretar a algún personaje en
gears of war 3
a su vez
ah
i
pero no debería decir cliff aceptó y
ahora es su voz la que escuchamos en el
personaje de griffin lo que alegró tanto
a este y que compuso una canción para el
juego lo gracioso es que aunque la idea
era mantener el rol de a está ya en
secreto no resultó del todo bien pues
unos meses antes del estreno del juego a
éste a través de una transmisión en vivo
para sus redes sociales accidentalmente
reveló que iba a participar en el juego
que estás retándome para terminar la
trilogía de gears of war con una
historia igual o mejor que las ya vistas
en los juegos anteriores contrataron a
karen traviss una escritora muy querida
por el equipo pues ya había escrito un
par de novelas de gears of war antes de
que se le encargara la historia de gears
3 lo curioso es que luego de que el
juego se estrenó o karen reveló que
nunca ha jugado ningún juego de la saga
para crear la historia del juego ella
sólo ve un par de cinemáticas de los
juegos anteriores y arte conceptual para
darse a sí misma una idea de la
ambientación del juego y ya con eso en
mente y sin siquiera haber partido ni a
un solo locus con una motosierra ella
creó la historia de gears of war 3 casi
a ciegas si durante la secuencia
iniciales del juego te quedas cercado
todo el tiempo y no te alejas de él ni
un segundo al despertar verás como todos
los personajes tienen una poderosa barba
vikinga igual a la de dom si incluso a
nia
eso me prende si comienzas una partida
en el modo horda en el mapa desde el
sherwood smart podrás ver a lo largo del
mapa tres generadores si le disparas a
cada uno de estos generadores aparecerán
una parte del mapa un rifle
francotirador rodeado de creel que te
atacarán si te acercas demasiado pero
hay una pequeña posibilidad de que en
lugar de el francotirador una pequeña
espada aparezca y si tienes mucha suerte
y le disparas a los tres generadores y
en cada uno consigues una espada tu
personaje morirá
pero luego se levantará rodeado por los
creel y al desaparecer tú y todos los
que estén jugando horda obtendrán un
arma especial
durante el desarrollo del juego se
eliminaron varias armas una de ellas era
una enorme ballesta que lanzaría
distintos tipos de flechas pero por
falta de tiempo no se incluyó en el
juego final el master boomer fue un tipo
de locus que también fue eliminado de la
versión final este enorme [ __ ] usaría
un látigo de metal para karti además de
poder lanzarte desgraciados desde lejos
pero los locos no fueron los únicos que
perdieron soldados pues también se
eliminó del juego una criatura lambent
éste era el ambient butcher y se suponía
que mutaría ganando más resistencia y
dos extremidades que podrías tirar para
atacarte con sus enormes hachas
y ya como última cosa que se eliminó del
juego originalmente se tenía planeado
una sección en donde tendrías que
escapar usando una moto algo así
parecido a lo que vimos en gears of war
4 pero debido a que no les pareció que
encajaría bien dentro del juego dejaron
esta idea atrás este juego tiene varios
de lc pero uno de los mejores es la
sombra de raam este de lc fue planeado
no sólo para recordar al infeliz de rahm
y algunos de los sucesos del primer
juego sino que la idea era introducir a
personajes que sólo hubieran aparecido
en los comics de gears of war y que no
fueran muy conocidos para que así
ganarán popularidad y los fans de los
cómics pudieran ver a sus personajes
favoritos destrozando locust en el
videojuego epic games está obsesionado
con las gallinas cosa que podemos notar
en muchas partes del juego por ejemplo
uno de los intereses más conocidos y más
extraños del juego lo veremos al inicio
cuando estemos en la cubierta del bar en
una parte encontraremos cuatro tubos a
los que les disparamos y cuando lo
hayamos hecho una gallina aparecerá de
la nada la gallina de por si es
inofensiva pero si eres un cabrón y le
haces daño la gallina se convertirá en
súper sayayin y se volverá gigante
dorada y capaz de escupir fuego así que
tendrás que matarla antes de que te mate
a ti otro de los mejores sister ex del
juego lo hallaremos y jugamos en la
dificultad locura y llegamos hasta el
segundo capítulo del acto 4 en donde
dentro de una habitación encontraremos a
un pollo pirata con el cual debemos
interactuar y a medida que avanzamos
patear cualquier caja de munición que
encontremos y cuando pasemos la última
caja de repente el pollo pirata
aparecerá volando y soltará armas y
munición para que las usemos en nuestro
viaje
en gears of war 3 existe un arma secreta
algo
rara
flexión un arma que lanza pollos
explosivos ultra amados y que matan a
tus enemigos de un solo golpe de hecho
es una de las armas que nos da el pollo
pirata de el puesto anterior durante el
capítulo 1 del acto 4 si juegas en la
dificultad locura encontrarás un casco
muy escondido en los escombros pero si
lo logras ver y le disparas
desbloqueadas una habitación secreta la
cual tendrá una máquina arcade y si
interactúas con la máquina entrarás a un
mini juego en el cual te conviertes en
una gallina ultra poderosa con casco y
dos escopetas y tendrás que matar a
tantos enemigos como puedas existe un
error dentro del juego involucrando esta
misma máquina pues se descubrió que si
se pegan cuatro granadas de
fragmentación cerca al arcade y luego
inicias el mini juego al salir marcus se
convertirá en la gallina más masculina
de este mundo
anthony y benjamín carmen murieron
bastante rápido en los dos primeros
juegos
y para honrarlos su hermano clayton
carmine se hizo un tatuaje en su enorme
brazo con los nombres de sus hermanos
caídos todos pensamos que los hermanos
carmen estaban destinados a morir en
cada juego pero cuando al final de gears
of war 3 vimos que clayton seguía vivo
fue raro pero epic games no se quedaría
con las ganas de matar al 3er carmen
pues semanas después crearon un vídeo en
donde hacían burla de esto y muestran la
muerte alternativa de carmen en donde
muere electrocutado en la bañera vaya
manera de irse soldado nadie me dice que
él es toda una celebridad entre los
gamers tanto que hasta tiene su propio
cereal mamady ximo y en cierta parte del
juego encontraremos una máquina en donde
podemos escuchar a cold promocionándolo
lo curioso es que si interactúas muchas
veces con esta máquina en su lugar se
reproducirá el inspirador discurso de
kabul que oímos en gears of war 2
dt
pero ustedes
[Música]
si juegas una partida de multijugador en
el mapa gridlock y no rompes a ninguna
de las personas de ceniza del mapa al
terminar la ronda se reproducirá una
instrumental de la canción insignia de
gears of war mad world
lastimosamente no te la puedo poner aquí
porque youtube se pone un poco sensible
con estas cosas y la última vez que
usted la canción en un vídeo fue
inmediatamente desmonetización
youtube es un eastern y bello en el mapa
multijugador de compras se esconde uno
de los sister ex más complicados del
juego pues luego de encender tres
alarmas de incendios disparar a unos
sombreros y extinguir un par de llamas
podemos ver en una habitación secreta a
un desgraciado con un pequeño sombrerito
sacando los pasos prohibidos y ya en
este punto gears of war era una saga muy
querida por xbox así que era de
esperarse que microsoft le demostrara un
poco de cariño a la saga sacando al
mercado una edición especial del xbox
360 para el lanzamiento del juego esta
versión limitada de la consola no sólo
venía con un diseño especial sino que
tenía sonidos únicos cuando usabas la
consola
[Música]
es tan
hermoso en el capítulo 4 del acto 2
cuando estamos explorando un
asentamiento locus y estamos en la zona
en donde hay varios tickers enjaulados
encontraremos un lugar secreto en donde
podremos ver cómo los locus estaban bien
entretenidos viendo a 2 tickers pelear
afortunadamente este no es el único
secreto de este tipo pues cerca a esta
misma zona otra habitación secreta nos
mostrará a un par de locos trabajando
honradamente
hasta que la máquina con la que
trabajaban se estropea y termina
explotando los a todos
cuando el juego un estado en desarrollo
en epic games aún no estaban seguros
sobre el futuro de clayton sobre si
dejarlo vivir o mandarlo con san pedro a
la final decidieron dejar esta decisión
en las manos de los fans por lo que en
la tienda de avatares de xbox lanzaron
dos camisetas una que decía salvácar
main y la otra carmen debe morir la
camiseta que vendiera más decidiría el
destino de clayton
afortunadamente para él los fans
decidieron ayudarlo y así fue que el
tercer hermano carmen sobrevivió a
adquirir software 3 por si te lo
preguntas en epic games demostraron
tener un gran corazón y todas las
ganancias que obtuvieron con la ropa
virtual la donaron a hospitales
infantiles
[Música]
algo que la mayoría no esperábamos era
que al final del juego
marcus abriera su musculoso corazón y
terminara junto a nia porque no sé
ustedes pero tal vez estuve muy ocupado
partiendo locus
darme cuenta en qué momento han ya se
enamoró de marcus a ver a ver qué pasó
mis dudas eventualmente fueron aclaradas
pues en la novela es la que narra los
eventos de marcus el tiempo que estuvo
en prisión se nos cuenta que han ya
siempre estuvo enamorada de marcus y
ella constantemente le enviaba cartas de
amor a la prisión pero los guardias
siempre la rompían y nunca dejaron que
marcus se enterara de los sentimientos
de anya como dato extra sí porque te
quiero en 2016 se descubrió un interés
que había quedado oculto durante cinco
años este interés lo encontraríamos y
durante el capítulo 2 del acto 2 le
disparamos a tres monedas que están
extremadamente escondidas en serio son
casi imposibles de ver en una xbox 360
clásica no sé cómo se las arreglaron
para descubrir esto en primer lugar una
vez le hayas disparado a las tres
monedas desbloqueará una habitación
oculta en donde un par de locus saldrán
disparados desde el suelo y tendrá y
dispararles antes de que caigan algo así
como doctor pero para machos además de
que al terminar te daban premios
dependiendo de tu puntuación tomo cinco
años encontrar este secreto pero hey
valió la pena
y con esto terminamos el último vídeo de
la trilogía original de gears of war el
mejor simulador de romper madres
monstruosas me la he pasado de poca
madre realizando estos vídeos pues he
aprendido muchas cosas de una de mis
sagas favoritas y espero que tú también
lo hayas hecho viendo este vídeo como te
mencioné antes este es mi juego favorito
de gears of war y aunque ya tiene más de
una década aún lo sigo jugando de vez en
cuando y créeme que partir locos nunca
pasa de moda
es una pieza clásica en lo que es la
trilogía original de gamers es de las
mejores en todos los videojuegos así que
si no lo has jugado qué [ __ ] esperas y
si ya lo jugaste después pues juega lo
denuevo cabrón si tienes ganas de más
datos curiosos y testosterona al final
te dejo los dos otros vídeos que hice
sobre gears of war y ya que estás ahí
por qué no echarle un vistazo al resto
del canal como siempre si quieren ver
algún juego en uno de estos vídeos
comenten y yo les echaré un vistazo
hasta la próxima
[Música]